severe hearing deficit and became
dependent on hearing aids in 2001 he
went totally deaf and had a tiny device
called a cochlear implant surgically
placed behind his left ear he tells this
story of recovery in the new memoir
rebuilt this talk from the University
Bookstore in Seattle Washington his 50
minutes
Michael course writing has appeared in
Wired and he writes extensively on
science he is also a consultant for
educational computing he is here tonight
with his technological memoir rebuilt
how becoming part computer made me more
human following the reading he'll be
happy to take questions
if he hasn't answered questions already
and then afterwards will be signing just
to my right so please help me in
welcoming to the University Bookstore
michael chorost thank you all for coming
you know it's great to see you all out
here now before we get started a sound
check is the mic turned on are you
getting it okay free okay see I can
never tell how loud things are because
I'm totally deaf I only hear my own
voice when it goes into the device that
I'm wearing and it's my head and I can
change my volume level so which means I
never know how inherently loud anything
actually is so I always have to do sound
checks so let me introduce my book and
talk a little bit about some of the
themes in the book is as the introducer
said it is a technological Men Lord it
is a story of going completely deaf and
gaining my hearing back when the
implanted computer which you can see
right on the cover of the book that is
my skull on the cover people ask me that
and if you're not convinced you can see
that you can actually see the outline of
my face on the cover because a cat scan
captures soft tissue as well as bone so
that really is my face I think I may be
the only author in publishing history
the other picture of the insiders had
and the outside of his head on the same
book on her
I don't know if anyone else has that
distinction if you know if anybody felt
tell me because I'll be very
disappointed so let me just start off
forthwith with the beginning of the
party which sets up some of the ideas
that flowed through the book so I'm
going to start on page page one I'm
going to read two pages I'm impatient it
hasn't been a good morning I'm on a
business trip and have just arrived in
Reno
where I'm supposed to each of you people
at Tahoe for a study but the
chloromethyl at the airport won't take
my debit card I spent half an hour
canvassing the other outlets no luck
finally a man at one katakana game the
competitor and points me to a courtesy
phone dial 133 they usually have cars
and their rates are okay I pick up the
phone I can hear fine even meet the
ruckus of the baggage claim yes they
have cars available the voice directory
to the shuttle bus outside the airport
at the last telephone call I will ever
make with my natural ears people work
signed I wait for my car I pigeon I
might as well have driven here instead
of flying and then that's odd the
traffic sounds fuzzy all of a sudden
instead of the usual decisive run the
cars have started making a whispering
sound as they go by as if plowing
through shredded paper and they sound a
hundred yards away even though I'm right
by the very it sounds like my left
hearing aids battery is going even
though I'm wearing two hearing aids only
the left ear really counts the right ear
is so poor that can only hear vague
rumbles my left ear is my conversation
ear my telephone ear my radio ear a
switchback batteries in a practice
little potty do of the hands left
battery into the right right battery
into the left that doesn't make any
difference
I guess they're both going
and as a matter of fact I have to
interrupt myself got the battery my
flame just died at this very moment so
this is actually a great opportunity for
me to introduce the implant itself you
know this is what we call the processor
and I'll hold it up for a moment so the
camera can get a good look at it it
looks like a hearing aid it's not a
hearing it's actually a computer it's
out for its data whereas a hearing aids
out for it is sound so here's how it
works
salmon cat is in a microphone in the
headpiece a little dot right there the
hippie send it to the processor which is
this device here this is the battery
which has just gone dead this process is
the sound saying they're back to the
headpiece the headpiece will stick to my
head
just like that the reason it sticks to
my head is because there's a magnet in
it inside the implant there's also a
magnet and you can see the implant
itself on the cover of the book and so
this device here behind my ear is the
actual body of the implant itself the
implant is embedded in my skull and it
has 16 electrons that govern each mahat
inside my skull and the triggering
auditory nerve endings in rapid sequence
to stimulate my auditory nerves my brain
has learned to interpret that as sound
you know normally a wait a bit in
reading to explain that except my
battery just went dead so I took that
opportunity so that's an extraordinary
coincidence I'm just talking about I
thought my batteries are dying and lo
and behold my batteries actually dying
so let's come back to the reading I
guess they're both going both batteries
I pull out a battery pack for my
suitcase do a second changer and wait
for the familiar rush of clean loud
sound but it doesn't happen I can't
- broken hearing aids at once it's as
absurd as two tires blowing out at the
same time as I get in the car and
breathing shallowly and it's not because
of the altitude and all the car window
down fiddle with my left hearing aids
volume control and wait for my ears to
miraculously clear all the way up to
Tahoe I'm monitoring on all frequencies
and this doesn't sound right gotta be
the batteries it's just a pack of bad
batteries at the hotel I check in then
guards the longs drug store and buy
three sets of 675
it cost me 15 dollars and 37 cents right
there at the checkout counter I'm
drifted batteries out of the plastic
case and put them in that doesn't help
either in the car I spread both hearing
aids out on the passenger seat and
methodically try every possible
combination of terms batteries and ear
molds nothing works
the day is like a coin that always comes
up tails
it's got to be earwax I say to myself
out loud looking out the windshield at
the big red and white logo of the store
I've got to get someone to check my left
ear for ear wax leave the clerk of the
hotel she had proved to be a listen
woman with blond hair layered over black
who's full of spouted as her hands
explored keyboard at Quincy maybe she
would also take me into her arms and
tell me that everything would be all
right you know that would be customer
service that never had earwax trouble in
my life but I've also never had two
hearing aids fail early and once either
emergency room now so that's how the
book starts and that happened on July
7th 2001 at 10:30 in the morning so as a
matter of fact I just passed the fourth
anniversary of my death dang the day
that I went completely deaf so the book
takes you through the process
or I was lying to be completely deaf and
tweaked after the sheer shock of having
the computer take over at my hearing and
that's where I was trying to convey in
the book they're trying to help beyond
having the book be a memoir of just
going death and gain my hearing back
that's a remarkable story in itself I
wanted to go further to talk about what
it was like that computer controlled my
hearing so let me talk a little bit
about that computer and by the way the
way I'd like to do readings it did some
reading and talking for a while take
some questions do some more reading so
once I show you this device I'd like to
invite you to ask some questions and
we'll do some Q&A I like that kind of
backward forth process so this is a
cochlear implant it doesn't look like
much in a distance but this is 40 years
of research and development
this device cost about eighteen thousand
dollars its actual value this device is
zero because this is the device that
failed quality testing so it was
rejected that's why I'm holding it here
instead of me implant it inside a
person's body so I'll pass it around be
careful not to yank on this because this
is the leads that go to the electrode
array at the very end
now the tip of it doesn't look like much
it just looks like a long piece of
plastic but that again is the product of
decades of research and development
this curled up inside the inner ear
inside the cochlea and there are 16 tiny
electrodes and you can see them if you
look closely on it those electrodes of
which stimulate the auditory nerve
endings now one of the things that I get
a big kick out of in looking at this
device is it says Advanced Bionics
Clarion platinum series model AP 0 5 1 0
0 H this side and now that's just
completely cracks me up because the
screen has supported this side out
instead of this way sorry J so let's
keep it this side out
and by the way you can see that's why I
hate peach sticks to my head because it
just sticks to the magnet inside the
implant so I'll pass this around yeah
could you pass that along thank you yeah
does anybody have any questions that
they would like to ask before I go on
yes sir there is research going on in
developing electrode arrays that have a
larger number of electrons yes can they
if they get one can they put one in you
that is possible
it's not likely because certain are
reluctant to X plants that is remover
device that's functioning properly
because you run the risk of doing
additional damage to the cochlea if much
of the device does a small amount of
damage they do a tremendous amount of
research to make that insertion as not
traumatic as possible but still and it'd
be moving it runs the risk of additional
damage now that said there are number of
patients with had their devices fail and
so the surgeon does remove the device
importing a new one and if the newer
ones are more advanced devices they'll
get a more advanced to buddies and
researchers found that those patients
tend to do as well more better with
their it with the new implant as they
did with the old one so it is proving to
be feasible in practice but still I
don't know if any surgeon that would
remove a properly functioning device for
the purpose of upgrading that's why the
device upgradable to software and that's
the primary way of operating the device
or loading new software into the
processor the processor uploads a subset
of that software each of the device
itself so the device itself is very much
controlled by the software that's
written for him and that is one of the
major themes of the book talk about how
different kinds of software profoundly
changed my perception of reality and in
a moment I'll read one of those sections
I mean any any other questions yes sir
does the implant have its own
yes it does oh you mean the eternal
implants yes no it does that's where the
really interesting things about it it's
got two computer chips inside it
something's gotta run the way it works
is that the headpiece is sending data by
radio through the skin the antenna
inside the implant picks up the radio
signal but it also uses it to induce an
electrical currents electric media can
be converted into electricity so it uses
that both as a source of data and as a
source of power so the implant here is
actually controlling this processor and
the internal processor yes sir you did
an incredible amount of remapping to get
it to where you're asked to speak up the
the implant and in the beginning you did
an incredible amount of remapping that
to get where you're at now since the
book has been published I mean what is
your situation I mean in remapping to
get better nobody asked me how many
mapping sessions I have to go through or
no light go through those sessions where
are you at right now in getting to it
more I guess okay stable first let me
just introduce the concept of mapping
you know there are some audiologists and
in there the cochlear implant users in
the audience so this be very familiar to
some of you but mapping is the process
of tweaking the values of the software
in the device there are many parameters
that can be changed by the audiologist
the patient can change some parameters
like volume and sensitivity
are there many other parameters that the
audiologist can tweet because every year
is different in particular every damaged
ear is different because damaged ears
are damaged in different ways so a
cochlear implant very much has to be
custom fits in the ear and that process
that custom fitting is called remapping
so I went through you know about five or
six mapping sessions in my first year
and in those sessions mean approximately
closer and closer toward a map which
worked well for me now that I'm about
three and a half years
implant I haven't had a mapping session
in about two years
I pretty much stabilized on a map that
works well for me now whenever I get a
new software I have to go through a
mapping process again
however the audiologist can extrapolate
from my old software and insert those
values into the new software so that
it's not completely starting fresh all
over again
so with most patients their map tends to
stabilize after year or so nonetheless
and here's a complex process so let me
read a little bit about you know let me
read a little bit about it what it was
like an activation to give you a sense
of what that was like so that is in
Chapter four
okay so I'm going to start reading on
page 50 I'm going to read about two and
a half pages
iseman let me start on page 52 sorry
and there are two characters in the
scene there is Becky white or yellow
just and cash who is another audio and
just then kiss turns to me and says the
big moments he warns me that I may not
like it that it may sound robotic where
voices may sound like minimaps i nod
deep down I don't believe I think it'll
sound better than that and I see that
the audio that what he's a smart and
because you've been through this many
times then he hits his laptop's Enter
key static it's like when Murphy the
sidewalk and Robocop first opens his
eyes all he sees as TV snow all I hear
is static there's a pervading roaring
sound that I can't even begin to locate
everything sounds awful muddy and
incomprehensible I stammered out
something just to hear my voice and it
sounded like rusty train wheels
squeaking through mud I've got the
expression of a man who's just swallowed
when he thought was Pepsi only to find
that it's actually pepto-bismol Cashman
Becky do a few exercises to put my new
ear through its paces I closed my eyes
to eliminate lip-reading at the each
recite the days of the week in turn I
can make me pick out the singsong
cadence but I can't be sure when one
person has stopped and another person
has started even worse I can't tell
their voices apart then we try assorted
words I get a few of them I scream
telephone when I'm wrong as often as
right give me a sentence I say I'd like
that something I can contextualize I'm
feeling like a man skidding down a hill
grabbing her after any
just love the fall care says this visit
is perverted again I say this is phase
for virgins I sign a spinach spinach and
cheese omelet I say everyone wars and
delight except me I got it right but I
know that I'm doing it based on the
cadence of the sentence and the one
syllable I could actually feel that I've
heard the verse out in breakfast it's
like solving a crossword puzzle all I
needed was one or two letters and a bit
of context it's mid-morning after all
I'm not actually hearing you now give me
a sentence I can't predict I say again I
experienced a woodling sensation that I
just learned corresponds to speech but
it's like squinting at a poster through
yards of fog the word color is black and
dog surface somewhere in my mind as if
someone were telepathically beaming the
words into my cortex again I say trying
for confirmation cache repeats the
sentence a third time
I found this can't be right for what I
think I'm hearing is what color is your
black dog open my eyes Cassius smiling
and nodding that's what I said it's
hardly an argument this the things
define my expectations would have got it
anyway I must have heard it a scowl on
him it doesn't feel like I heard you it
felt like guessing and it does it feels
like reading a page with half the
letters whited out one might be able to
skate over and get the gist but it isn't
going to feel like reading it will get
better Becky says it will get better
cast ends Margaret and Paula helpfully
give me excited thumbed up signs better
how I'm thinking even if it gets twice
as good as this it's still going to be
terrible
the session comes to a close as I stand
up I'm so stiff that I have to crank my
head back and forth a couple of times to
unlock my neck I'm paying the fee from
being switched on and walked out on
wobbly feet so that's what I heard the
first hour after arms after meeting so
in a bit I'll read a little bit about
different kinds of software which is
getting it son of the philosophical
themes of the book in fact let me jump
right into that section now and then
we'll break for a few more questions
so I'm going to be talking about two
different kinds of software called CIS
and sis
yeah CIS and SAS have an average phased
out so these are our dated pieces of
software this was back in 2001 but just
give your inkling sis fired all of the
electrodes all of the time
CIS sorry did I just say C as SAS fires
all the electrodes all the time CIS
fires just one of the electrodes and any
given instant but it's drugs among them
so rapidly get the illusion that all the
electrodes are being fired
it's like television where only one line
on the screen is actually being lit and
any given instant it just happened so
fast then you give you a learning of
continuous motion so the two programs
are profoundly different ways of
stimulating the auditory nerve endings
so here what's talked a little bit about
how that sounded to me so I'm going to
start on page 72 about halfway down the
page
so over the next few weeks I
experimenting I thumbed my dials
endlessly wind chimes on CIS wind chimes
on SAS mom's voice on CIS mom's voice on
SAS Mian serious me on assailants I soon
discovered yet CIS and SAS had very
different ways indeed of handing me the
world see is the first program I had
used it activation gave me this for
ventral nervous SAS gave me blood your
heart for orphans CIS made the world
sound quiet metallic and tinny SAS made
it sound big blocky and fuzzy see is
minced as I asked a loved see is dead
nice and neatly with chopsticks SAS
threw it at me Indrani shuffle phones
one new version of the world would be
unsettling enough if the sky is suddenly
always green you can at least decide to
accept that as reality and do your best
to get used to it but if you have a
choice between world where the sky is
green and pink and the other your sense
of reality goes right out the window I
had never heard the world mine thing or
galumphing shop licked or shoveled to be
sure the implant delivered roulade essa
bills I could hear clock ticking across
the room but I did not feel like a
hearing person a hearing person huh I
was a receptor of a flood of data which
I was constantly stitching into the
meaningful language a half second or so
after I actually heard it and my
performance outside the testing birth
was terrible with even minor background
noise or on the phone and lost people's
words like saw dust in the wind all I
knew was that I had two different
versions of reality and they both sound
long so let's break for a couple more
questions
yes sir I'm just curious about your
perception of the difference between
sort of solving three different phases
where you had hearing that wasn't wasn't
perfect and then when you went totally
deaf and now are there things that were
positive when you're a totally deaf for
the things that you missed from that
phase or was it all just you're just
glad that's sort of behind you so if I
understand you right you asked me about
you asked me if there's anything that I
miss about being totally deaf and well
let's just start off with that question
that's a very interesting question you
would think that going totally deaf
would be a nightmare and you would be
right because it cut me off from the
social world the biggest problem is that
I couldn't use a telephone I could still
have conversations with people one on
one and then lip-reading skills were
very helpful and I still have a little
bit of hearing left in the right ear
so all of a sudden my right ear became
really really important to me so I
became much better at lip-reading then I
had ever dreamed I could become as a
matter of fact I would say that three
months in which I was totally deaf was
more than most alive times of my life
smallest size my life where I felt the
most engaged with people and with the
world because the experience of going
deaf was such shocking and such sudden
that my response was to marshal all my
energies and say this just happened I'm
gonna go through it and solve this
problem and I knew about cochlear
implants as a matter of fact the dam was
deaf I flew back from Tahoe back to San
Francisco and you know my mother what is
an audiologist
so I already knew something about
cochlear implants so it was the sense of
terror and despair
I knew the technology was out there I
didn't know whether I would be a
candidate for the technology but I knew
that was there
and I knew that I was in for a profound
change and I never think to myself as I
flew back you know I might be able to
get a book out of this experience I
actually thought that I swear so he was
a very alive time it in lifted me out of
that humdrum routine and it gave me this
very exciting process and technology
confronts I was also very scary one
morning L just gave me the implant and
she gave me a person the a plant with a
casing that can be removed it's like I
should open it up and look at the
circuitry inside and but overwhelming
thought was oh my god it really is the
computer because I could see the two
computer ships and was very clear that
they were hundreds of thousands of
transistors in the thing and was this is
going to go inside he's going to
actually control a part of my hair so it
was terrifying
but it's also incredibly exciting
because I've been a science-fiction geek
all my life so science fiction this is
another big theme book so thank you for
asking the question because it lets
begin it's never a theme of the book
which really you know Chuck really loved
to talk about you know there are many
movies out there in Hollywood which
depict cyborgs in one way or another and
a psych ward is a fusion of human and
machine or to be more accurate a few of
computer and human being so I was going
to become someone who was both was part
of a pewter and part human and I had
seen Robocop ain't singing The
Terminator
I admit Martin King's novel cyborg which
was the inspiration for the Six Million
Dollar Man
and all of those are about they try to
convey where the experience is like in
one way or another and so I keep to this
experience with that science fiction
framing my expectations so I was about
to find out how right were they and that
was actually very exciting so in the
book I talk about that so in many ways
science fiction has gotten it completely
wrong Suffolk's they have a Borg in Star
Trek so how many here a Star Trek fan
okay well okay one person but thank you
very much for being in the audience well
I know we have another Star Trek fan
over here
so in Star Trek there are these creepy
characters called the Borg which all
these mechanical electronic parts and
their bodies and it turned them into
shambling robots so there's this
reflexive assumption that having
technology integrated within your body
makes you in you and I think that's
absurd but people just make that
assumption reflexively someone's
confront that in the book okay so thank
you for letting me take that question
far feel from your original question but
let's have another question yes parents
of deaf children strongly oppose
cochlear implants why would that be okay
the question is I've heard that some
parents of deaf children and in fact
some deaf people strongly opposed
cochlear implants and the reason is
there is a subset of the deaf community
that's the signing deaf community the
primary language is American Sign
Language now American Sign Language is
not transcribed and it's not
fingerspelling we spell out English
words one letter at a time
American Sign Language is a completely
different language than English that
means that people have learned ASL from
childhood for them English is a second
language and it's often a poorly learn
one because they don't have access to
the sounds of English so people grow up
being fluent ASL or effectively living
you know linguistic subculture they have
their own language their own culture
their own way of life and so some people
fear quite reasonably in my opinion that
if young deaf children get cochlear
implants but the parents will not be
motivated to send them each of the
signing deaf community they fear that it
is a harbinger of the ending of a way of
life the ending of a language the ending
of the community that's what's at the
bottom of that resistance yeah that's it
in my pocket talk of
my perception of how attitudes have
changed in some members of the signing
deaf community there's a university for
the signing debt called Gallaudet in
1993 student protests forced the
cancellation of a of a seminar of
cochlear implants in 2001 however
there's a survey and 59% of Gallaudet
faculty and students agreed that the
university should encourage students
with cochlear implants to attend so
there's been a sea change in some
people's attitudes over time however the
basic issue of the future of ASL I think
it's still very much up in the air and I
do talk about that extensively in
chapter 8 of the book and also one of
the things that makes the issue
emotionally charged for me let me say
first of all I don't speak ASL I was
always raised as an oral deaf person my
parents didn't know ASL so I never
learned as though I never spent time
with ASL speakers because my period made
the choice that I should learn to speak
in here English but ASL is such a rich
vital and vibrant community and it's a
world in which I might have felt fully
included and fully at home so just
before my talk today I was talking to
member in the audience and has a son who
has profound hearing loss and who wears
hearing aids when you're in that
situation you're neither in the hearing
world nor in the signing deaf world here
it's an awkward place in between I've
always been at that awkward place in
between so I feel a sense of an ending
for the signing deaf community to live
in a world where you can communicate
that person effortlessly I've never had
that experience so for me it's a very
emotionally charged and resonating
question as it is for many members of
the signing deaf community it's a great
question thank you okay I'm taking one
more question they do another meaning
yes if you had not been a candidate for
the cochlear implant or if in the future
something should have
to make it impossible to continue to use
it would you put your energy into
learning to sign absolutely because it
would be first my only choice it's like
an ASL is a beautiful and fascinating
language so as a matter of fact if
cochlear implants have been available I
probably wouldn't read in a book about
that transition from the hearing world
it's the signing deaf world and some
people have done that it would be
another transformative adventure so I
certainly would have done that it's now
is an extraordinary language um you know
just to give you a slight flavor of it
again I don't speak as an ASL speaker I
just speak as someone who is read about
ASL and who has talked to people about
ASL you know English has rats of
synonyms so the word good there's
marvelous terrific magnificent amazing
cool ASL has a small number of signs for
good but you can Fleck them with your
body language so you can precisely
convey how good something is by the way
you hold your body by the way you make
your face light up so if I was an
incredibly good language for telling
jokes for telling stories for gossiping
for shooting the breeze its
extraordinary language and an
extraordinary community so I absolutely
would have done that and cochlear
implants are now available and some
people do make that choice but I chose
to be being a hearing person and that
was a choice I'm very grateful that
medical technology gave me the choice
okay yes
some people's two languages speak French
and they speak English or Russian
anything with it
is there some reason not to do both if
you have a cochlear implant this is okay
it's a great question question is why
not be bilingual why not simply speak
both ASL and English and that is
certainly possible however there is a
difference you can be bilingual and
saying Russian and English or Spanish
and French
but it helps that two functioning years
for them so if you have a hearing loss
and if you learn eight if you aren't ASL
that's great but it's very hard to learn
spoken
language so it's not quite the same
thing because people who are deaf don't
have the access to spoken language that
people with normal ears do you know some
parents do wrestle with the question of
whether to teach their children both
English and ASL and some parents do try
to devote it however it is difficult if
the parents don't speak as though in
fact 96% of the deaf children born in
this country
abort the parents who don't speak air so
only 4% are born to parents whose native
language is ASL so finally give a
loyalty it's possible practice and in
theory and practice I think it's
challenging to achieve okay let me give
you another piece from the book and
we'll wrap up at around 8 so let me city
what's marine now I think I will read a
piece about the piece of a Radio Shack
so Lucky's flip to that page so this was
a couple of days after I was activated
to celebrate my new year I go out to buy
my first portable CD player I want to
play my familiar old CDs as a way of
mapping my new auditorium world onto my
old one not only help bolero sounds or
any rate did sound through hearing aids
and cochlear smishing most of their hair
cells will help me reconnect to reality
whenever exactly that is these days I
start by going to RadioShack to get a
cable which will enable me to connect
the CD player to direct me to the
processor the processor has an audio
input jack for just this purpose I'm
greeted immediately by young attentive
and rather expressionless employee what
can I do for you I'd like to get a patch
cable to connect to a CD player
I say you're connecting it to a speaker
he asks I have a thing
how do I explain this I decided to give
him the short first and let him ask
questions to figure it out in his own
way I point to the processor input jack
and my waist I'm going to plug it into
this now before I go on let me just say
that there are two different versions of
the processor I'm wearing the ear level
version which looks like a hearing aid
there's another verse it looks a little
like a pager and it says on the on the
waist and that processor has an audio
input jack into which you can plug just
about anything so that's the version of
the processor that I'm talking about I
point to the processor
input jack in my waist I'm going to plug
it into this but he doesn't ask me any
questions
he leads me to the back and rummage is
authoritative Lee among cables hanging
in plastic bags he can't do my
consisting of three jacks on each end a
study this doesn't look like it should
only have one plug on each end you're
going to plug it into a speaker he says
again no I say my points of the process
or at my waist and then to the back of
my head this is a bionic ear the patch
cable will go in here then the sound of
dog eats my head he simply nods and
turns back to the cables on the wall I'm
a little be funnelled maybe his
customers walk teach the store all the
time
asking how to plug things into
themselves he fix out a cable and hand
it to me can I try this at first I say I
want to make sure it works he muscles up
a CD player from the display case and
slide the disc into him I peek of the
label it's country-and-western
he keeps the player in his hands which
unnerves me because I don't know what
the heck is going to happen I entertain
a brief vision of a searing pain in my
head followed by both me and my credit
card
dropping limply to the floor killed by
George Stream
well if I can't control the CD at least
I can Jack the path cable out really
really fast
I oughta recently take hold at the end
on my side just before he presses the
play button it's music the sound quality
isn't all that great but the feed comes
through clearly an hour later I'm home
with a patch cable and a new walkman as
I sit down on the couch to listen
Elvis artis is back and Rawls barely
able to greet me and as you can tell
from the contacts Elvis is my cat okay
not Elvis the musician but you know I'm
a totally deaf man who was a cat need
for a musician it occurs to me that
there's no way he can hear the music if
I were wearing headphones he'd be able
to hear whatever little bit of sound
leaked out but I'm plugged directly into
the player its output goes directly into
the processor which converts it to
binary and pass it on to the implant the
implant decides which electrodes to
trigger in my cochlea there are no
physical vibrations anywhere all Elvis
is ever going to hear is the slight hum
of a player itself I'm hearing music
that never actually exists as sound this
creepy evidence of a profound
transformation and how urine beings
taking information for the world around
them or it could just be a cozy domestic
scene a cyborg and his cat full layer of
zips by energetically accelerating as it
goes Elmo cementec attentive little
cat's eye I can feel his breath coming
out his nostrils and lays his head on my
arm so why do you like also put a
picture of Elvis on my website and by
the way I have business cards which will
pass out which give my website which is
www.hyken.com
so you can go there and you can actually
download the first chapter and you can
also download clip
there are simulations of what the world
sounds like from a cochlear implant
they're absolutely fascinating so you
know highly recommended that people
listening to them and often it's
actually kind of shocking for people to
listen to those simulations because it
makes you realize that as amazing as a
cochlear implant is it's not a
substitute for a normal ear it doesn't
fix the ear what it does is it creates a
simulation of hearing it's not perfect
but a very proud of the fact that I
can't and do use a cell phone that is
extraordinary that is a signal
achievement that in this day and age it
is possible if you're totally deaf
people to use cell phones so anyway we
have just a couple of minutes left so
let's take a couple more questions and
then we'll wrap up yes yes I do must
because the is that this thing comes off
undef so biologically I end up the
reason I here is because a computer is
doing a hell of a lot of data processing
for me so yes I still consider myself
very much a deaf person I'm also a
person with hearing loss so I still have
to struggle to hear things sometimes a
person will call me my cell phone not to
say I'm sorry I can't just tell me who
you are
so that I can contextualize what you're
saying so I certainly had to work harder
to hear that a person with normal
hearing I my right ear is still deaf so
I still have only one functional year
well the way I haven't seated getting an
implant in my right ear
my surgeon is urging me to do this and
maybe I will do it something but right
now there's no crisis you know it's a
very dramatic process to go through
maybe someday and we'll do it Western
technology that besides just better and
better micro
the source or software that they're
doing for people with you sort of
hearing loss so you asking other other
technologies that cochlear implants that
are used for hearing loss well there are
all sorts of research going on about
deafness and one way or another there's
a very exciting stranded research which
is focusing and actually recalling that
damaged hair cells inside the cochlea
and may actually be possible someday to
cure deafness a cochlear implant is a
prosthesis it simulates hearing but
science isn't doing research in two ways
of regrinding the hair cell and that may
indeed be possible so that's very
exciting there's research going on of
course in better hearing aids hearing
aids are improving all the time
there's also Nicias like there are that
kind of hearing aid called the Baha
which is actually implantable hearing
and there are other kinds of hearing
aids which physically move the small
bones in the inner ear so there are a
whole range of technologies available
for people who are deaf and hard of
hearing so if you know someone who has a
hearing loss and if they haven't been to
an audiologist in the last five years
it's definitely time to go again because
the field is exploring all sorts of new
technologies and new therapies it's a
very exciting time yes we had a question
here
can you yeah I thought I saw you had a
question
you mentioned that difficulty when you
first got the implant how long did it
take you to adjust to that and be able
to discriminate
well the question is how long did it
take me to adjust to what I first heard
when I was activated
how long did tank work this vis vis
proverb is to sound like what did you
have for breakfast I've so first say
that it's different for everybody it
depends very much on your hearing
history adults we've had normal hearing
from most of their lives tense with that
very rapidly - cochlear implants because
they have a fully functional one Ettore
cortex young children tend to adapt very
rapidly to cochlear implants I'm
actually somewhere in the middle because
I was a person who never had a normal
hearing and therefore I'm an
underdeveloped auditory cortex so we
took probably longer for me than it
would take for many other people so I'm
saying um you know as you can tell from
that excerpt that I read I was getting
benefit the first thing the first day I
was getting environmental sounds I could
hear a clock ticking 20 feet away that
first thing I'm saying going to took
about a month for the telephone to
become somewhat intelligible to me and
maybe four or five months from reading
become comfortable and using the
telephone and actually the telephone
comes up over and over and over in this
book because the phone is the ultimate
test for a cochlear implant user if you
can use the telephone you can hear so
for me it's a the timeframe was weeks
and months and even now three and a half
years later you know I'm still
discovering that I can hear things that
I hadn't heard before so it's always an
evolving process so it is different for
everyone okay we had I think a question
there yes sir two technical questions
one is on you comment in the book about
using software that other people have
written has it or anybody any people
hacking their own digital hearing aids
so there
implants does anybody release the sauce
you know the great question questions
anybody hacking their own color in flood
now we have two more dollars in the
audience who may know more about this
than I do so feel free to speak up I
would love to be able to hack my own
cover name like how nothing must be able
to get a hold on to the laptop and
Soundwave the software used a program I
in Flint and start fussing around the
parameters um I don't think my own yells
whatever allow me to do it because you
know I think in theory you could create
parameters that could harm your ear so
you've got to be the hands of
responsible professional but nonetheless
I would love to be able to play for my
arm parameters I do know that it's some
cochlear implant centers they do give
some patients um they did let them
directly control the laptop to set some
of their own parameters and I would love
to do that so different centers have
have different styles basically and me
someday you know I will be able to
persuade the maker my implant Advanced
Bionics so let me have some wave but you
know I would have to know a great deal
about you know the mechanics of the
software wait years whirring there's
also at the technical terms you know
what do y'all just spend years going to
school to learn these things there's a
good reason for it it's not the kind of
thing where you just kind of figure out
in half an hour
okay so I don't know if anybody who does
um dude okay you don't like nobody else
know of anybody who doesn't you see for
digital hearing aid I don't know either
and in order to do that kind of hacking
you have to have the physical connection
to the device
so cut everyone needs to physically be
able to connect to it you can't just
plug it into your PC and start fooling
around with it well maybe for an
electrical engineer okay I'm not an
electrical engineer okay where's your
second question second questions related
to that is about how you use your cell
phone as a drink yeah Bluetooth in your
that would illuminate be the cable how
do I use my cell phone
yeah well Bluetooth would be great I
don't know of any company that's
actually researching that right now the
way I use it is just the way people
normally hearing music I just stick it
up against my ear yeah I actually
didn't explain my devices microphone
very well I say that sound goes in the
microphone here and it can but this
device the microphone is actually here
it's a very clever design because the
taste invention of the curve of the year
so it takes best if I come bouncing off
the shell the year into the microphone
so it adds a few decibels of sound to
the signal it also makes it much easier
in the you know cell phone because I can
put it right there now that took some
getting used to for me because with
hearing aids the microphone is
technically on the front of the device
like around here so I had a lifetime
experience putting the phone here but I
still nothing by myself put it here
well I got to tell you another funny
story and then we will wrap up because
it's exactly eight o'clock um when I
first got this t-mike I was just sitting
there tightly stuffing my laptop by
accident I kind of wrapped my arms
around my head like this and I suddenly
discovered that I stopped hearing oh my
god it took my hand off a guy that's
ionized in here yeah whoa now I can hear
here's the bizarre experience doesn't
experience that everybody normal hearing
takes for granted but for me the center
of my here and can never been here it
always been here or here where you hear
sometimes so it took me a while to get
used to the fact that my here was
actually here you know it's experience
that the other six billion people on the
planet take for granted three it was
totally new I felt like a three-year-old
so and that's the kind of experience
that you have over and over again with a
cochlear implant just to wrap up you
know that is one of the biggest themes
of my book
Westlife learned how to live in a new
kind of body in a body whose rules are
different and in a body whose rules can
be changed over and over and over again
okay you've been a wonderful audience
thank you all so much for coming
whatever
[Applause]
michael chorost is author of rebuilt how
becoming part computer made me more
human it's published by Houghton Mifflin
on the web at Houghton Mifflin books
calm